when you think of the largest tech
companies in the world what names come
to mind probably Apple Microsoft Google
Nvidia Amazon and meta right well what
about broadcom did you know that
broadcom is currently the ninth largest
tech company in the world in fact they
boast a market cap of
$570 billion as you can see broadcom is
clearly one of those background
companies that grown way larger and way
more powerful than anyone realized I
mean just take a look at their stock
graph it's basically a rocket ship
having grown
74xl 2009 alone for perspective even
Apple has only grown 32x during that
time period and it's the same story with
the rest of big Tech as well Microsoft
only grew 17x Google only grew 13x and
Facebook has only grown 10x the only big
tech company that has really outshined
broadcom in terms of growth is NVIDIA
whose stock graph is is an even bigger
rocket ship having grown 177x during the
same time period but there's one massive
difference between Nvidia and broadcom
for quite some time now Nvidia has been
involved in multiple super hyped up
Industries whether it be crypto mining
soft driving cars or most recently
language models Apple literally created
the iPhone and Google Facebook and
Microsoft created or acquired services
that are used by billions of people but
broadcom on the other hand well that's
as boring and background as it gets
that's why they've been able to go to
nearly being a top 10 company without
the general public noticing but that
doesn't mean that you should take a
broadcom lightly broadcom estimates that
99% of all internet traffic across the
entire world passes through at least one
broadcom chip and they've produced quite
a few skeletons to get to that point in
fact just recently they completed their
acquisition of VMware for $69 billion
which has turned into one of the most
controversial Acquisitions within the
tech world so here's what you need to
know about broadcom the truth about how
they got so large and why people in the
Noah are so worried about
[Music]
broadcom taking a look back broadcom has
been somewhat of a dark course within
the tech industry since the very
beginning way back in
1961 one of the main reasons for this is
that broadcom was never some sort of
humble startup that was cherished by its
consumers at any given point in time
rather they started in the shadows and
they stayed in the shadows you see
broadcom was originally started as a
division within HP in 1961 called HP
Associates 1961 was very much the stone
ages when it comes to the tech world but
HP had already made a name for
themselves having been in business since
1939 they were known for making cutting
Edge audio oscillators and radar
technology that were famously used by
Disney and the US military during World
War II as such broadcom or HP Associates
was launched with a great pedigree and
plenty of resources but for the first 30
years you wouldn't have even known that
they existed in fact broadcom's own
corporate history page only has a few
bullet points describing their first 30
years of business which really just
enters on three inventions the first of
these inventions was gallium arsenide
Fifi LEDs these LEDs are what you see at
traffic lights and big LED signs their
second invention also had to do with
LEDs they were the ones who created the
world's first commercially available LED
dot matrix displays and lastly moving
into the 1970s they also created the
first fiber optic transmitters and
receivers these three inventions
provided them with plenty of business
behind the scenes especially when
combined with the brand image of HP but
this is not what really made a broadc
into what what it is today for that we
have to fast forward to the early 1990s
to the early days of the internet you
see while all of the VCS and
entrepreneur hopefuls were piling into
the Internet space hoping to make it big
one Professor student pair named Henry
samil and Henry Nicholas at UCLA would
decide to sell the shovels if the
internet was truly going to become the
next big thing everyone was surely going
to need a way to connect and get access
to the network and this is precisely
what this Duo would address together
they would found a small private company
called broadcom in 1991 and they would
begin developing integrated circuits
that would make the internet work if
you've ever wondered how in the world it
was possible to get an internet
connection using cable TV lines well you
can think these guys unlike HP
Associates these guys didn't really have
a reputation or connections it was
really just the quality of invention
that did all the Talking their first few
customers themselves included the likes
of Time Warner Rockwell International
Analog Devices and even the US Air Force
these customers alone would provide
broadcom with over $5 million in annual
revenue and attract the attention of
Intel who would loan the company another
$5 million and if you're wondering what
all of the hubub is about then I think
these numbers will really put things in
perspective at the time phone-based
internet offered speeds of up to 28.8
kilobits per second broadcom's cable
based Solutions on the other hand
offered speeds of up to 1,000 times that
and they would soon move over to
revolutionizing the phone Internet space
as well hearing all this you're probably
wondering where all the controversy is
so far this is really just a feel-good
story about Ingenuity and Innovation
that made the whole internet what it is
today and it definitely could have been
exactly that but pretty soon our
professor student Duo would lose their
way after seeing big dollar
signs
by 1998 broadcom would grow to
11,750 employees across 15 countries and
they would go public with an insanely
successful IPO that made both Founders
into sentim millionaires they could have
just held on to their Stakes for the
long term and they would have become
Deca billionaires but what they really
wanted was a larger portion of the pie
leading us into one of the biggest St
scandles of the era options back dating
options back dating was an extremely
prevalent Scandal throughout the late
'90s and early 2000s and it involved the
likes of Apple United Health Group
Staples The Cheesecake Factory KB Homes
monster and of course broadcom how does
it work you ask well it was all due to
one misguided accounting rule that was
implemented in
1972 the rule permitted companies to
avoid disclosing executive compensation
if it was in the form of stock options
this wasn't a big deal at the time or
for the next 25 years really because
stock options weren't nearly as popular
back in the day but that would all
change with the rise of dotom companies
all of a sudden billion- dollar fortunes
were being minted overnight thanks to
stock compensation so naturally stock
compensation became far more desirable
than cash compensation and pretty soon
these Executives would discover a
loophole within the law given that
companies didn't have to disclose stock
option grants for investors at the the
time in which they were granted the
whole system essentially ran off the
honor System it was up to the executives
to be honest about how much stock
compensation they received and when but
let's just say that a lot of tech
Executives weren't exactly honest
essentially they would team up with
their executive buddies and create false
paperwork that made it seem like they
all received a bunch of stock grants 5
years ago when the stock was 50 times
cheaper and it was now up to the
investors to pay out these massive
compens ations through the form of stock
dilution this practice would end up
costing investors over $10 billion $2.2
billion of which was allegedly due to
none other than
broadcom after these Revelations came to
light both Founders would step away from
the company but they were never really
held accountable the cases against them
would eventually be dropped due to
prosecutorial misconduct and broadcom
would end up settling for just $160
million both Founders would end up
walking away as Deca billionaires but
this Scandal would forever stay in
broadcom and turn them into the dark
course that they are today after this
massive Scandal broadcom very much
needed a way to reset and move forward
and this is where the other half of
broadcom would come into play remember
how we started off the story talking
about HP Associates well this is where
they would become relevant right before
the turn of the century HP Associates
would break off from HP and become a new
company called agilant Technologies
this company would then be purchased by
KKR and silverick partners in 2005 for
$2.7 billion creating a new company
called avago Technologies avago would
lurk around the Shadows of the tech
world for the next decade before they
finally made their move in
2015 they would agree to move forward
and acquire the entirety of the stained
broadcom for $37 billion bringing us
into the modernday
broadcom
honestly there's really nothing good to
say about the modern broadcom which is
such a shame these guys are literally
responsible for creating the tech that
makes the modern internet possible yet
their behavior really makes it hard to
root for them for starters it appears
that they're patent trolls in 2017 for
example they sued Smart TV makers for
patent infringement and in 2020 they
sued Netflix also for for patent
infringement The Tech Community at large
just views these lawsuits as broadcom
suing because they're jealous even the
judge that was ring on the case said
quote you're killing me calling the
filings massive Overkill but their
patent Tantrums are the least of your
worries the far bigger issue is that
broadcom controls the entire internet
chip Market calling them a monopoly is
honestly understating the situation
again keep in mind according to broadcom
themselves 99% of all internet traffic
passes through their chips so basically
every company that you can think of in
the entire world is riant on broadcom
and I'm not just talking about tech
companies broadcom has Fortune 500
customers in all of these industries and
let's just say broadcom is very much a
predatory service provider for these
customers you know things like predatory
contracts retaliation on non-loyal
customers exclusivity arrangements and
so on I mean you can't feel too too bad
for these Fortune 500 customers because
they usually turn around and do the
exact same thing to us but the point
still stands that broadcom is very much
a toxic Force within the tech World they
control an invention that basically
everyone needs and they leverage that to
the Max and more recently they've been
looking to expand their Monopoly to
adjacent sectors in 2017 for example
they would attempt a hostile takeover of
the mobile chipmaker Qualcomm for $105
billion the only reason that this deal
didn't go through is because president
Trump would block it but it's not like
broadcom was really all that upset about
it because they would just move on to
their next acquisition Target in mid
2018 for example broadcom would go ahead
and purchase CA Technologies a tech
infrastructure giant for $18.9 billion
in cash and most recently they completed
their acquisition of VMware for $69
billion every time that broadcom
completes an acquisition they make sure
to spread their toxicity and that's why
much of the Tech Community has basically
just accepted that VMware is basically
dead at this point it's very similar to
what GE was doing back in the 80s and
90s but instead of it happening in the
industrial world it's happening in the
tech world and honestly the only way
that this will likely end is by broadcom
becoming so big and so toxic that they
crumble from the inside out until then
though they're very much a force to be
reckoned with that you should be aware
of and that is the truth about broadcom
someone else who has been investing a
bunch into Acquisitions is none other
than Microsoft and it may end up
backfiring check out this video to learn
more but until then I'm Hari and I'll
see you guys on the next
one